dr nash and total transformation who is
sponsoring this next segment have been
transforming lives across the valley for
for years and for veto it is more than
just weight loss take a look
on dr nash's program i lost 170 pounds
and this is the result jaw dropping dr
nash veto's results 170 pounds this is
incredible tell me more vito came to me
along with his wife who was struggling
and battling cancer and he was obviously
morbidly obese and he had made a promise
to his wife that he was going to change
and unfortunately she passed before he
got to the final result but he kept that
promise to her losing a hundred and
seventy pounds so he was just one of
those good old boys from the bronx in
new york that was able to target those
metabolic issues that had driven his
stubborn weight loss and get phenomenal
results and that was three years ago
you've talked before about a fatty liver
and how that could preventing people
like veto and others from losing weight
tell us more about
about the fatty liver
yeah so that was actually one of vito's
problems is that he had something called
fatty liver disease it's also one of the
things i found out that i had back in
2009 when i fixed my problem what people
don't know about fatty liver is that it
plays a key role in your body's ability
to burn fat because it is the only organ
that
turns your body fat into the fuel which
means if that problem is going on and
you're unaware of it it's probably
working against you in reaching your
normal weight and then staying there
will diet and exercise fix a fatty liver
a lot of times if we do get told that we
have fatty liver disease from our
doctors they might suggest that we need
to lose weight but it's actually not the
extra weight that's driving the fatty
liver and it's not your extra body fat
that's getting trapped in the liver this
is fat being created by the liver itself
that should not be there and it makes
the liver function kind of like a
clogged toilet if someone wants to go on
a diet and make some changes should they
go see their doctor first
if they want to get confirmation that
they have fatty liver disease they could
potentially go to their doctor and they
would have to get advanced imaging so an
mri and ultrasound a cat scan to find it
but even then here's the sad thing jc
there is no drug or medical treatment
for fatty liver disease and as it
progresses it turns into cirrhosis and
then liver failure
so fatty liver is 100 reversible but it
is not reversible by simply losing
weight and it is not reversible by any
medical treatments with your doctor so
if you feel that you might be struggling
with a fatty liver getting it tackled
now by doing a program such as mine
would be the best course of action
and we saw the results from veto just
fantastic again so happy for the guy dr
nash you always bring a special every
week what do you have for us this week
i do so normally when people book the
online evaluation with me by calling my
office directly they're going to get
charged 97 for that online evaluation
but whenever las vegas now allows me to
come on and talk about these important
topics i always like to do something
special so we have 10 online
appointments right now
for over 90 percent off 9.97 you can
find out if you have any damage that's
driving the stubborn weight problem how
you get it corrected for good and how
you get your body to hold that weight
loss while eating two to three thousand
calories a day